[Music]
welcome to the sky news daily podcast
with me
dermott monahan thanks for joining us as
we examine the story
beyond the headline now 2020 has been
the year where lockdown
social distancing working from home and
telling your colleagues there on mute
became something of the norm the kobit
pandemic has also had
huge repercussions for businesses and
has been possibly the biggest political
challenge
faced by a government in peacetime
they're fighting a war here and they're
losing
it a tsunami it's a recurring theme now
everyone dies alone you've got masks
gloves
overalls they've just been left there
can you level with us how many people do
you think will actually die
you must stay at home they're going to
do everything they can to save him but
the odds are stacked against him i don't
want to be a
sister to this dude there you are
it takes you down boris johnson has
tonight been admitted to
hospital i just got better and he didn't
this used to be a theater now it's just
a stallion
we're having to struggle to get this
equipment in place it's appalling really
i wonder if you will take this
opportunity to apologize
a first for british muslims ten burials
one straight after another it's the
biggest
day that we've had in terms of falls
since 1987.
i'll go get out i'll go get some fresh
air i can't take this anymore i can't go
on
i'm sick and tired of this when is this
going to stop they ruined
my results this is not what i deserve
you can see him just there
running across the downing streets and
out the back gate
how is it help biblical
it just brings a little bit of joy to a
lot of people at a time when
that's exactly what they need you really
want to give people a hug every night
this is a day to remember frankly in a
year to forget
it's all for prison that's right
hopefully it'll help other people come
along
and do as i did
what a year it's been joining me on this
special episode of the daily skies
economics editor
at conway and sophie ridge i say what a
year it's been
unprecedented extraordinary we run out
of words don't we but i mean
first of all you know how's it been for
you guys everyone's been affected
personally i mean is there anything in
your
domestic life that has just you know
changed utterly
well i don't think i've ever had an
experience i'm sure you guys
are the same where your work life and
your personal life have
so completely collided so what we're
reporting on now
is what we're talking about with our
friends on whatsapp it's what we're
experiencing with our families
and it feels to me like everyone is
going to have a different
experience of the year whether you live
alone if you have a
young child like i do that has a huge
impact on um
how you found the last year and locked
down it's just been
a life-changing year what are you
personally everything's kind of blended
into
you know work and and personal life have
blended into one
and it's just you know the same for
i imagine you know millions of people
around the country trying to
you know we you set up a kind of
barriers between the two
and you know i find that kind of
difficult at times but listen
i mean one thing is we're all in work i
mean that that we're going to do
yeah that's very true i mean i'm at the
other end of the of the age scale from
you guys so the way it affected me was
with my
my mother she's in her home and i saw
her in
you know it's hard to remember i think i
saw her just before the lock and about
the 5th of march and then i
didn't see i wasn't allowed to see her
for the almost the entirety of the
summer
and i tell you guys you know i don't
want to start lay down about the
deterioration in her
mental position because of the lack of
contact has been quite marked
and and you know i know this has
happened you know to millions of
families around the country and this is
this is what we've been dealing with
what about um
working from home you've been in the
studio a lot we're going to talk about
that in the studio a lot but actually
but also
you know we set up a kind of a rig at
home so i could do
stuff from my my study at home
constantly living in
fear that my one of my two daughters is
going to come in
we're going to get on to uh you and your
enormous list of data charts
shortly but first um that moment that
changed the way we lived our lives in
2020 we all remember this
huge numbers are complying and i thank
you
all the time has now come for us all
to do more from this evening i must give
the british people a very simple
instruction you must stay at home
all together isolating and staying
indoors obviously that's instructed but
it's just the fact that we've got a
little a little or no
or no space it is really really tough to
deal with because normally we'll go out
to the park
and get some fresh air but you know now
we're just cooking up inside and
with little or no space to store food
as well that's another challenge
it's destroying parents mental health
because there's no places to go you're
scared to go out
it's stopping people from wanting to go
out how many mental healths are getting
destroyed
how many families aren't being fed how
many children aren't sleeping at night
with woody
okay well let's look at the lockdowns
and sophie i mean i re when i heard that
clip from boris johnson again i mean it
brings it all back i remember i was
coincided with
with sky news tonight i was put outside
downing street it's just down the road
here
and we kind of knew what to expect i
mean it had been well flagged that
lockdown was coming but i remember when
he announced those words it was like an
electric shock yeah it's like you felt
like you were living through
history like this is something that
people are going to be talking about in
decades that we've been told to stay at
home
and i remember i probably about a week
before
i had a conversation with some people in
number 10 and they were like yes
you should be scared in fact everyone
should be way more scared than you are
right now
everyone will know people who get ill
from this and that was a nine moment
when i was like
oh my goodness this is and there was
that there was that point pre
the lockdown that was march the 23rd as
i remember but there was that kind of
shadow period when you you know when
when you had the pubs open but don't go
to the parks and
and there was that sense and if you i
mean drill down into this anymore was
that sense that the government was going
to try
a different route what's happening
called the swedish model you get a real
sense that that was the way they were
attempting to go and then they then they
really saw the numbers totally i think
that's right and also i think what we
have to
remember as well is that the sage advice
early on
was actually very different to what
we're getting now i mean for example
they were saying that
mass gatherings we remembered cheltenham
well they were the sage scientists were
saying
that actually there's very little
evidence that these really have a big
role in transmission
i mean look how wrong they were then and
the mask used face masks as well
um that there's people were saying on tv
at the time that actually maybe they
make transition worse because people
aren't wearing them properly it just
is a big reminder i guess of how far
we've come on that
and ed i remember you and i in this very
newsroom early on in that lockdown
having a conversation i came across to
you and i said
how can we afford this and remember the
initial lockdown was three weeks it was
going to take us up to easter it was it
was the original
circuit breaker it was to save the nhs
to
to
build this space and i said even three
weeks i remember saying to you
you know give me ballpark figures how
much is this going to cost
and i don't know what i said to you
about that i mean even then it was
for three weeks it looked mind-boggling
it was it was it was extraordinary
numbers and that's kind of where we've
ended up i guess you know what
what policymakers would say is that even
if we had followed the swedish model the
damage would have been
as great if not greater because there
would have been so much
concern that people just wouldn't have
gone out and behaved as normal so it's
not
it's not a question of life would have
been the same we would have had some
economic gains as
we would have had even more economic
catastrophe and more deaths
that's the argument the reality is the
entire world has had to go on an
enormous learning
kind of mission here and a lot of stuff
we got wrong
a lot of stuff and still are and you
know still learning
so for electric moments the prime
minister the night the queen
spoke to the nation yes shortly after
and clearly
everyone wanted all attention on her
majesty then it comes
overshadowed people have almost
forgotten that address
the prime minister was taken to hospital
two days later
he's in intensive care it was
extraordinary that time was ex i mean it
was electric like you say those electric
moments where you just take a breath
it's almost like a breathless moment i
think we all remember
that when the prime minister did go into
intensive care has been one of the
clearly um most memorable moments of the
crisis it was quite frightening i think
because boris johnson wasn't old yeah uh
you know okay he was
obese but um at the same time this is
the prime minister he's one of the most
public faces that we see on tv
almost every day he's in intensive care
and then also
i think it's only a few weeks afterwards
that we realized there was a vacuum in
government at that time
i remember we're told that you know he
had his laptop there and was watching
with nail and i and joshing with all the
stuff we later found out you know he's
putting in an induced coma and he's
he's he needs help breathing why not
tell us that oh and the statistic
you know we could all see it from the
statistic and a lot of actually the
weird thing is a lot of my job has been
just looking at the numbers and trying
to ignore
all of the words around them and in that
case the statistics were saying that
you know he there was a very significant
a tangible chance that he might die in
intensive care
that it was very real and when he looked
at the outcomes that we've seen in
intensive care
um particularly for those who are
overweight it wasn't it was not good
just a quick one on this while we're on
this on this section is of course you
know the economic response and
and from both of you i mean you know the
speed at which rishi sonic and that
treasury team designed
in particular that that furlough scheme
a word again we weren't
particularly familiar with i mean ed
were you impressed
i was yeah no i was impressed and i
think you know a lot of people
actually interestingly you know dominic
cummings spent a lot of the last kind of
year or so saying try essentially trying
to kind of
get the treasury out the way because
they were seen as being in the way
they weren't seeing it as being a kind
of fast responsive unit if you had
a crisis they weren't seen as being
particularly imaginative
and yet in the crucible of this enormous
crisis
it was the treasury that was kind of
very quick to formulate something that
was totally unprecedented i remember you
know
we talked about it on those evenings
when when the news came out
this was an unprecedented policy and you
know
yeah and to the extent that it's touched
everyone as well
you know it is to some extent a bit like
a wartime situation where
millions of people are directly affected
by a government policy in a way that
actually
they very rarely are registered you must
have talked to him on
on the sunday show i mean he was he's a
rookie chancellor i find it fascinating
i remember when
uh number 10 were first pushing him on
the sunday show we were like who's this
before hobart who's this richie scenic
guy you know can't you give us someone
more you know
famous well-known they were like no he's
going to be a star trust us on this and
to be fair he is one of the emerging
political stars of the crisis
yes i take the point that in the years
to come
will his star continue to rise because
that is when many of the very difficult
economic decisions are going to come
on the recovery on the way out but right
now you've got to say that rishi sunak
is somebody who
has in 2020 has been one of those more
reassuring
political figures for people let's uh
concentrate now on some of the data
that inform those decisions we must keep
reducing
the incidence of this disease we must
keep that
r down below one and that means we must
all remember the basics wash our hands
keep social distance
isolate if you have symptoms get a test
sage has advised that a circuit breaker
should act to reduce r below one
should reset the incidence of disease to
a lower level
and should set the epidemic back by
approximately 28 days or more
for every day that we release we'll need
two days of tighter restrictions
so coming into christmas we need to be
very careful about the number of
contacts that we have
and then i think once we have got past
the christmas period
we will all have to be very responsible
and reduce those contacts again
okay now we're concentrating on the data
so it's got to be you ed because you
spent so many hours i mean it must have
added up to
two weeks in front of those screens and
just let me ask you first of all
personally i mean obviously you know
you've got this huge
economic brain was it easy then to to
turn it because you're used to dealing
with data was it easy then to turn it's
all this
medical and scientific stuff you were
dealing with the r8 et cetera et cetera
weirdly yeah loads of the stuff that
i've been doing this year has been about
the numbers what do the actual numbers
tell us and is it any different from
what the either the scientists or indeed
um the skeptics are saying that's the
thing is that
you know i mean i know you you ventured
on to the bear pit that is twitter with
this data
and that's only i have to because um
but but i mean there are i mean
there are so many big divides there's
such a divide
about the data it's what you touched on
earlier pure
science well you've got these numbers
but people
interpret them in so many different ways
and getting so cross and angry about it
but rightly so given the stakes you know
this is people's livelihoods at stake
and i think
you know rarely is it that there's been
an issue which has been so data centric
that has had
such a tangible immediate and sometimes
you know really terrible impact on
people's lives
and i think people are scared we heard
particularly when dominic cummings
was there that this kind of nasa-like
setup with the data just coming in from
from all over the place and that
remembering it now that's then when we
started this
this tier system and then you get these
regional divisions and some people
saying well hold on a minute your
incidence level or your r rate is higher
than us but we're in a higher tier
than you it's really difficult and there
are different things to weigh up so
obviously it does feel incredibly unfair
if you're in seven oaks and you've got
really low instance rate
and yet you are being put in a higher
tier than many of your neighbors
you know it's happening in places in
derbyshire and language all over the
country
i had i remember talking to one
politician though uh the mp for oldham
it was saying oldham's got a very high
rate one of the problems that they had
in greater manchester at the beginning
was
that it was too small the areas they had
different rules and different areas
people were confused the messaging was
very difficult so
and that they were criticized for that
so it's like you have to balance all
these competing things and
i think in some ways that is why it's
been such a
difficult crisis for politicians because
there are
it is very on the one hand this on the
other hand that
there's no easy solutions to this now we
spoke of the human cost of kovi 19 in
the first of these special
daily podcasts but the economic cost
has been a high price for many as well
today i can announce that for the first
time in our history
the government is going to step in and
help to pay people's wages
we're setting up a new coronavirus job
retention scheme
any employer in the country small or
large
charitable or non-profit will be
eligible
for the scheme it's great to hear what
the government are saying that they're
going to support us
which is actually taking a load off my
shoulders because i thought
you know i could lose everything you
know i could 28 years of being in
business
and it's just but i've now got positive
head on my shoulders
it's a horrible horrible situation to be
in
it's you know it's it's worrying about
how long is it going to take him to find
a job there's
800 applicants for one job how
how do you compete with that on that
basis
heaven knows when he could find a job
well sophia i mean just first of all
characterize for us the divide and there
is something of a divide
within government you know we understand
i mean as as he should do the chancellor
is
constantly referring to the damage that
the economy is suffering and there are
these
constant tensions definitely i think
what's interesting is even in
the core sort of quad if you like a
government there are there are these
splits and we can see them we know for
example that russia cena is increasingly
concerned
about the economic impact and then you
have matt hancock on the health side now
of course
in a way you'd expect the chancellor to
be worried about the economy and the
house secretary to be worried about
the health but you've seen these kind of
switches in the middle too
so michael gove for example it feels
like he has drifted more and more to the
hancock side
of the argument there's also big
questions about boris johnson
starting off kind of on the kind of
rishi soon ak end but then of course got
very ill
became much more concerned about the
health risks of covered
more in favor of the lockdown and i
think now we can see the prime minister
perhaps edging back
more into the rishi sooner camp ed i
want to take you back to those charts
and again you know these
these searing memories they must have
been for you when you were pointing to
some of those charts i mean what
gdp hitting the floor and i think the
historical comparison was sometime in
the 18th century or something like that
the hit but i mean the
the 1709 yeah okay the great frost 1809
18th century but i mean the truly awful
one is is unemployment and there's
so much more of that to come through the
system yeah i think that's right and you
know even now
you know towards the end of the year
it's still we don't quite know how bad
it's going to be and partly that's
because just
unemployment takes quite a while to go
up uh and partly
it's because it's difficult to tell you
know because the furlough scheme has
come in
and it is an extraordinary intervention
it's supported
millions millions of people you know we
just heard from some of them there
who might otherwise have have lost their
jobs or you know not being able to pay
their bills
so the scale of it is massive and the
amount the impact on the government's
finances is
is massive but also it just means that
we don't quite know
how bad it's been across the economy as
a whole and we probably won't until the
follow scheme comes to an end
you know in the march if you talk to
people in the treasury they're
really concerned about the longer term
impact not just of
the furlough scheme but also about the
revolution in the workplace we've seen
so increasingly people working from home
obviously that has a huge impact on city
centres
it also means that if you're working
remotely then when the next
you know job reviews come up you're not
just competing against people who can
commute into the office you're
communicating
against people around the world let's uh
stay with the politics it's fair to say
the government would probably rather
forget
some of these moments so let's have a
listen
covered 19 isn't a surprise um it's not
happened overnight we knew that it would
come in
and why we're having to struggle to get
this equipment in place
is it's appalling really
there is understandable anger but a lot
of that anger is based
on uh reports in the media that that
have not been true a lot of people would
say that i ought to have
called the prime minister i have to make
make decisions and sometimes i make
do the right thing and sometimes i make
mistakes
i got bbc but i was expecting aaa so
they ruined my results this is not what
i deserve
okay well let's examine those lessons
learned
well sophie do you think they have been
learned or they're they're still
learning i mean we just touched on a few
of the
extraordinary number are they u-turns
there's been confusion on messaging
which has been absolutely damaging
throughout the pandemic when you need
people to understand a clarity of
message
and i think it's in particular you know
we heard from the exam situation there
that for me was one of the most
avoidable uh crises of the last year
actually they should have seen that
coming there's no reason why they
shouldn't
realize that if you don't set exams how
are you going to mark people
uh is there a bias towards private
schools which there was in the system
i feel like the education side of this
is where they really just
i mean we've got the dominic cummings
one of the clips in there i mean the
handling
of that it seemed to fester for a long
time and then he went anyway yeah i mean
look it's it's no secret is it that the
prime minister expanded an awful lot of
personal capital keeping dominic
cummings in place
and then he went in the end anyway as
you say was it worth it i think in
retrospect
you might say no we talk so much about
the new normal about things will never
be
the same again but we saw you know after
the financial crisis i
i remember saying similar things it
pretty much you know when things got a
little bit better
they pretty much reverted to the norm
what are your thoughts on that
i feel that we are potentially becoming
more appreciative
and i can probably see you guys rolling
right now i remember the first lockdown
when i got my first takeaway coffee and
i honestly i remember skipping down the
high street i was like this is amazing
it was like yeah well listen i had that
like such a treat like a lot of people
had a 14-day quarantine you know when
you're not even allowed out of your out
of your front door you can't even
exercise which i found
a bit weird i mean you know that 15th
day yeah
wow walking down the street yeah the
whole country so that's the roaring 20s
thing isn't it you know actually
well they were all a bit everyone's a
bit nervous now maybe when they're
finally unleashed
then it's an extraordinary summer get
your dancing shoes out
yeah finally to go with your socks ed
sophie thank you both very much and
that's it
until next time head to sky news for the
latest on the covet fight fightback lots
more
information analysis and explainers as
well on our mobile app and social
channels
thanks for joining us for this edition
of the sky news daily podcast hosted by
me
dermot monahan and produced by annie
joyce
and mark thompson and don't forget to
subscribe on apple podcasts or whichever
app you prefer
and if you've enjoyed this please do
leave a review